yeah because there's an a comfortability
so you just make me so [ __ ] angry
sometimes oh it's just like it's like
what I've been obsessed with of 90-day
fiance so I've watched like all seasons
yeah and I'm telling you guys I want to
marry a Mormon boy it's official and
he's so angry that this is my final
decision
[ __ ] it dumbest thing I've ever
stumble one it's garbage don't watch it
it is it is basically garbage TV but
I'll tell you that
a quick premise is that people fall in
love with somebody from a different
country whether it be because they met
in that different country or they found
him online and then that person comes to
the United States and they have 90 days
to figure out if they're going to get
married or not so they get a green 99%
of it is me it is somebody that wants to
become an American citizen Oh green card
yeah it's like the one that we saw I
mean I glimpsed it last time we were
watching it that older white Midwestern
Omaha and her the guy is how old is he
20 to 26 and he's like a half old how
old is she she's a 43 year-old like
nobody wants to [ __ ] you I'm just six
kids so yeah yeah but no no at one point
yeah but at 44 with [ __ ] six kids
it's over kind of well you're not gonna
get a [ __ ] 26 year-old Tunisian guy
who's a good-looking maybe know what I
seems like green card yeah Filipina
because after they got married after you
got his green card he split so obviously
that's it but there are stories there
that are so heartwarming and all of them
involve Mormons and that's why I want to
marry him there's so sincere and there's
no just can't drink coke I'm okay with
that that love that I see in them is so
really they're still pure all right I'm
I'm seriously converted I think I was
like I want you to become a Mormon I
might I want you to go to Utah meet some
white dude in the Mormon I'm telling you
right now in three weeks you'll call me
come home Papa I don't know
I got excommunicated yeah because as
soon as you stick your finger in their
butthole but that's what your move yeah
they're gonna be like what what are you
doing yeah that's what poop comes out
hmm
yeah yeah you're not gonna like it I
don't think they have rules about like
sex though they only have rules about
like getting having sex before marriage
but like what they do in prop 8 was that
the the marriage proposition oh the gay
one yeah it was prop 8 might have been
yeah yeah they were that the Mormons
were the ones that like those anti prop
8 yeah campaigns they funded that okay I
regret what I said I mean we have so
many you know ideas about I just thought
about I have stopped watching the
[ __ ] show it's [ __ ] you up 90 day
fiancé
[Music]